Hello everyone and uh welcome to lecture
9 of CM295.
So as you know uh today is a kind of a
special day because uh we're having the
last lecture of the entire course. Um so
the menu for today will be a little
different compared to usual.
uh we're going to try to divide the
lecture in three parts. So in the first
part we're going to recap actually what
we did in the entire class
just to see how different pieces kind of
fit together. Uh in the second part we
will look at some topics that are
particularly trending uh in 2025 and
what we think are going to be trending
in the near future. And then uh the
third part will be more uh way for us to
just conclude and uh next steps uh for
all of you.
Does that sound good?
Cool. So with that uh we're going to
start with the first part which uh what
I mentioned is about recapping what we
did this entire quarter.
So nothing new here. It's just a way for
us to piece everything together.
So if you remember u lot of weeks ago I
believe it's like maybe 10 weeks ago we
had lecture one which was focused on
understanding what transformers were. So
at the very beginning of the class we
didn't even know how we could process
text. So I guess the first step that we
saw was this tokenization step which
consists of dividing the input into
atomic units. And so here the way you we
divide the text is something that is
arbitrary in some sense. So we have
different algorithms that allow us to do
that. Uh and we saw that the most common
tokenization algorithm is the subword
level tokenizer.
And we saw that some of the advantages
were that um roots of words could be
reused um and leveraged especially when
it came to representing those tokens.
And
speaking of representation,
once we were able to divide the input
text into atomic units, aka tokens, the
next step for us was to learn how to
represent these embeddings. So if you
remember, we saw some methods that were
very popular back then. So one of them
was called wordtovec
and the representation was learned from
a proxy task which was something like
predicting the center word or predicting
the context words.
But then we saw that this way of
learning representations had some
limitations.
One of which was that these
representations were not contextaware.
Meaning that uh if a word is in a given
sentence or in another sentence they
will both have the same like that word
will have the same representation in
both sentences.
And so for that reason we saw some uh
other methods that were popular in the
2010s. one of which was
RNN's if you remember. So RNN's um had
this recurrent structure which process
tokens one at a time and kept an
internal representation of the sequence
so far.
But then we saw that a big limitation of
this was this problem of long range
dependency and in particular the fact
that uh tokens that were encoded far in
the past were not um quantities that
were able to be kept I guess as the
sequence got longer
and this is the reason why we saw the
central idea of this whole class which
is the idea of self attention where
tokens s can actually
attend to one another regardless of
where they are placed in the sequence.
So you can think of this as a direct
link.
And so uh this for instance is what we
saw. We we saw that there are like three
main uh terminologies that people use.
So query, key and value. So typically
you want to know how similar a query is
compared to the keys in the in the
sequence and you quantify that by um
taking some dot products that's kind of
scaled and softmaxed
and then you have the corresponding
value that is taken. So at the end of
the day we obtain some kind of weighted
average of all the tokens that are in
the sequence.
And then uh you may also be familiar now
with this formula. So soft max of q
krpose over square root of dk um time v.
So this is the matrix formulation of
what I mentioned here which uh is able
to process these computations in a very
efficient way and it's something that uh
today's hardware is well equipped to do
and then we finish the first lecture by
going through the architecture that is
the foundation of modern day LLMs which
is the transformer and we saw that there
are two u not notable parts in the
transformer. So one was the encoder in
the left part of the uh um the figure
and then the right part is the decoder
and we saw how this was applied in the
case of translation.
So at the end of the first lecture we
saw what motivated us to end up with the
transformer
and we saw that transformer was working
quite well in the case of uh translation
and so in the next lecture what we saw
was what were the little improvements
that people have made to this
architecture since it was released and
if you remember it was in 2017 that it
was publicublished.
So one particular improvement that
people have made is in the way we
consider positions
because in the original transformer
paper positions were encoded
in an absolute way as in each position
had its own embedding
and this embedding was added to the
token embedding.
But then if we think about it
positions actually we don't really care
about the absolute position. We care
about the relative position between
tokens
and in particular we care about how far
tokens are in the self attention
computation.
Which is why we saw this methods that is
now quite popular called rotary position
embeddings aka rope
that is now quite used. And it is a
method that rotates
query and keys
both of which happen in the self
attention computation.
And so here um what is uh quantified
here is purely a function of the
relative distance between um two tokens
and not only that it is something that
is uh taken care of in the self
attention layer which is what we care
about.
So this was one big improvement and then
we saw some other improvements
especially when it came to how the multi
head attention um layer multi head
attention layer was composed of and in
particular we saw that it was possible
for us to have some groupings
of the matrices that we learn. So we
don't need to have one matrix one
projection matrix per head for let's say
keys and values. We can actually uh
group them. So this is uh for instance
what is mentioned here. So group query
attention. Um and then we also saw some
other techniques that I have not
represented here like for instance the
normalization layer in the transformer
which here happens after each
sub layer but I guess nowadays people
have tried moving the normalization
piece before the sub layer. So here it's
the postnorm
version and then the before the sub
layer part is called the prenorm
version.
And then the last thing that we saw was
that from this transformer architecture
there were a lot of derived models that
were based from that. So we saw that if
we only keep the encoder part we could
compute very meaningful embeddings.
If you remember there was this um uh
kind of landmark paper on encoder only
model which is birds which was heavily
used in the context of classification
because it relied on the encoded
embedding of the CLS token. And so that
was one.
But then we also saw that there was a
number of other kinds of models all more
or less derived from the transformer. So
you could only keep the encoder which
was for birds. You could only keep the
decoder which is for instance for GPT
and you could also have both
which is for instance the case of T5.
And one particular aspect of each of
these models is that encoder only is not
able in the way that we saw is not able
to generate text
but is able to generate embeddings which
can be used for downstream tasks. But
then encoder decoder models like T5 or
decoder only models like GPT they can be
auto reggressive and
generate text. The paradigm can be text
in text out.
And with that we then focused on what
now everyone calls large language models
which are transformerbased models
specifically texttoext models. So
decoder only transformer-based models
and we saw that people have come up with
a lot of new tricks now because um you
know these models as the name uh
indicates um people have scaled them up.
But then one question was uh kind of
kind of thrown which is do you actually
need all these parameters to just do a
forward pass.
So we saw uh one kind of uh variant
which was based on mixture of experts.
So what mixture of experts are is
instead of running everything through
the whole entire model, you're going to
instead have a number of experts
that you're going to activate in a
sparse way.
So for instance, for one input, you're
going to just activate just a subset and
then for another input you're going to
activate another subset so that you
don't need to do all the computations
all the time.
And we saw that these mixture of experts
they were used in LLMs in particular in
the feed for neural network layer. So
here you would have experts as being
different feed for neural networks and
you would have a gating mechanism that
would reroute
to the correct feed for neural network.
And then we also saw that some papers
were also able to kind of produce some
nice visualization in terms of uh I
guess which token gets routed to which
experts because this rerouting we saw
that it was done at the token level.
And so one reason why it's done at the
token level is to be able to I guess
smartly put the experts on different
pieces of hardware, different GPUs and
then kind of parallelize the computation
a little bit more.
And then we also saw that these LLMs
they always are tasked with predicting
the next token. And in order to predict
the next token, we were interested in uh
I guess how we were uh you know doing
this. And so one particular uh method
that people use is just sample
sample from the output distribution. So
you have let's say given an input you
have a distribution of probabilities of
what the next token would be that is
output by the model. And what you do is
instead of let's say taking the highest
probability which is called the greedy
decoding
uh greedy kind of decoding you actually
sample.
So it introduces some randomness and
allows the model to produce kind of a
bigger variety of uh kinds of outputs.
And we saw uh that you could adjust how
how much I guess variety you want in
your output by tweaking a hyperparameter
called temperature.
So very low temperature leads to very
spiky distribution. So more
deterministic outputs and higher
temperatures are I guess a bit more uh
random a bit more creative.
Okay. So until then we saw what LLMs
were, how they were based on the
transformer, how they connected to the
architecture that we saw in the first
lecture and then in lecture lecture four
we saw how people actually trained those
LLMs
because as I mentioned these LLMs are
large and so you cannot kind of naively
fit them in your hardware. you need to
be a little bit smart about it.
So in particular, what people have uh
kind of noticed in the early 2020s is
that the bigger your model is,
the better your performance.
So people just started building bigger
and bigger models. So here in the uh
illustration we saw that so on the y-
axis is the test loss. So the lower the
better. So we saw that the more compute
you use the better your tests uh
performance and same with uh increasing
the data set size and same with
increasing the number of parameters
but then as you know compute is not
infinite. So there was a natural
question that came out of the community
which was okay if we give you a given
budget a given compute budget
can you choose
I guess some quote unquote optimal
number of parameters and data set size
on which you want to train your model.
And so we saw that there was this paper
that was um published in the early 2020s
uh which actually studied the
relationship between
um I guess if you vary the data set size
and uh the size of your model and the
performance on the test set.
And then we saw that actually most
models at the time were what we say
undertrained because they were too big
compared to the data set that they were
trained on. Like the data set that they
were trained on it was not as big as
they should have been.
And so in particular there was a kind of
a rule of thumb that came out of this
which was if you have a given number of
parameters in your model
you should at least train it on 20 times
the number of parameters in terms of
tokens.
So for instance, if you have uh a 100
billion parameter model, you should
train it on at least two trillion
tokens because two trillion is 100
billion * 20. So that's kind of the rule
of thumb that people have uh used and
then you know as I mentioned previously
you know these models are huge. So
people have tried to also make the
computation more efficient
and so there was this uh method that we
saw which is actually quite important
called flash attention
and flash attention is a method that
leverages the strength the strength of
the underlying hardware
and in particular it looks at so GPUs
more particularly it looks at the kinds
of memory memories that a GPU has.
So it has a big but slow memory and a
small but fast memory. So the HPM and
the SRAMM respectively.
And we saw that this method tries to
minimize the number of reads and writes
to the big and slow memory to the HPM.
And so the the way it was doing this was
to divide the computation in uh little
bits that it would send to uh the SRAMM
which is the small but fast memory so
that it can do the end to end
computation
and then send it back to where it was in
order to do the full end toend
computation.
So that method is an exact method
meaning that we're not doing any
approximations to the results
but it led to significant speedups and
in particular there was this second idea
from uh the paper which is a kind of an
important one as well which was that
sometimes
it's okay for you to not store results.
it's okay for you to just throw them out
and then recomputee when you need them
again. So there is this idea of
recomputation
using what I described which led to
faster run times even though we were
doing more computations.
So that was flash flash attention and uh
we also saw a number of other methods
that were meant to I guess parallelize
the computation. So we saw uh data
parallelism
which was this idea of not having all
your data be processed on a single GPU
but instead divided into uh kind of
multiple places.
And then we had the second method which
was model parallelism
where even for a given forward pass you
would actually involve multiple GPUs.
So anyway, there were a lot of very
interesting techniques, a lot of
different uh ideas about how to train
this model in an efficient way.
And uh in particular um so what I
described here is mostly important for
the first step of uh the training
process of an LLM which is called the
pre-training
which is meant to teach the model about
the structure of language about the
structure of codes. Uh and in particular
this model was trained with huge amounts
of data. So think about trillions of
tokens or even tens of trillions of
tokens.
Um and so that first step goes from an
initialized model to a model that is
able to autocomplete because it is
trained with an objective of predicting
the next token.
So at the end of this first stage, you
have a model that knows how to
autocomplete, but you have a model that
is not very helpful because it only
knows how to complete things.
So in order to have the model be useful
for our use cases, we had this second
step which is called the fine-tuning
step. uh where we teach the model on the
kinds of input output pairs that we want
it to perform well. So this is also
called uh the SFT stage supervised
fine-tuning stage. And at the end of
this second step, we have a model that
not only knows the structure of text and
codes, but also is able to behave in the
way you want.
But so far up until step number two, we
have only taught our model what to do.
We have not taught it what to not do.
And this is why we had our third step
which was the preference tuning step
where we took our model that went
through the pre-training stage that went
to the SFT stage and now we want to
inject some negative signal as well as
in I want you to prefer this compared to
this output.
And this third step uses preference
data. So like the name uh suggests so
preference tuning uses preference data
which is typically pair-wise data where
humans say okay I prefer this output
compared to that output.
And typically the model here is able to
align the kind of output it produces
with human preferences that could be
along the dimension of uh usefulness of
safety, friendliness, tone. Um there's a
bunch of different dimensions but uh
yeah so that's what is happening in this
third step.
And in this third step, it's actually in
lecture five that we dug into what that
third step was about. So if you remember
uh we had drawn a parallel
between the way our LLM produces tokens
and I guess what people in the
reinforcement learning field um I guess
consider how uh given policy is uh
interacting with some environment and
performing some action and being in some
states. uh and the reason why we drew
drew that parallel was to be able to
leverage some RLbased techniques
in order to train our model. So in this
case we said our LLM is a little bit
like a policy.
So given some state which is the input
it has received so far it can perform
the next action and in this case it is
to predict the next token
and this prediction is made in the
environment of tokens
and when we u like predict a completion
what we do is at the end of the day we
have some signal some reward part which
can be the human preference.
So this is the parallel we drew with the
RL worlds and with that in mind we
talked about rewards
but the problem is that rewards are only
available for a limited set of data
which is why we saw how to model
rewards.
So we saw this formula if you remember
it's called the Bradley Terry
formulation
which um models
how the probability of an output being
better than another one is as a function
of I guess two scores like the score of
output I and the score of output J. And
we saw that reward models they are
typically trained by having this
formulation in mind in a pair-wise
fashion.
So what this means is a reward model you
give it two outputs. You say this one is
good, this one is bad and then I want
you to say this one is good. You train
it in a pair wise fashion. But then your
model is actually predicting always two
scores. It's always predicting the score
RA I for output I RJ for output J. Um
and so at inference time you're only
giving it one output.
So I think that's like one subtlety like
we train it in a pair wise way but at
inference time we're kind of using it
in a in an individual way if that makes
sense.
And so once we trained our reward model
using this formulation
then we were able to use it to steer our
LLM towards the direction that we care
about.
So if you remember the way we steer our
LLM in the direction of human
preferences is to give it a prompt
so that it can produce a completion
aka a rollout or in simpler terms an an
answer.
And then we take this prompt, we take
this answer, we put them both in the
reward model that tells us how good the
model response is.
And depending on what the reward model
says, we can tune the weights of the LLM
in a way that maximizes human or the
reward that we saw which is trained on
human preferences.
And the loss function of this RL uh
setup
is typically something that tries to
maximize rewards
but also keep the model close to the
base model. And here by base model we
mean the SFT model. And the reason why
we want that is because this reward is
imperfect.
So we saw this uh phenomenon of reward
hacking
where your reward can be imperfect and
the LLM can exploit its imperfect nature
to tune it in a way that actually does
not align with what you want it to be.
So you want the LLM to not be too far
from the base model which is actually
already a good model. So it's a way to
regularize that if you want and you also
want the
iteration updates to not be too big
either.
So you typically have these two
constraints. You don't want it to
deviate too much from the base model,
but you don't want it to deviate too
much from the previous RL iteration.
And then just as a reminder, I think
this was lecture five. I think was the
most technically challenging of the
whole class. So completely fine if the
first time you were like you know what's
happening. Uh but hopefully now it
should be a little bit more more clear.
Uh cool. And then after lecture five
we're like okay we've done a lot of uh
hard work. So uh the good thing is you
know we're in 2025 and in the past 12
months or now 14 months we've seen a lot
of models that were being released with
these reasoning capabilities
and the way they were trained to exhibit
these advanced reasoning capabilities
was actually leveraging a lot of the
techniques that we saw in lecture 5
just like oral based techniques.
And in particular, what we want our LLM
to do is to output a reasoning chain
before producing the final answer.
And the reason why we wanted to do that
is because people have seen that it
improves the performance of the model.
And so it's actually relying on this
idea of chain of thoughts, which I
believe we saw at lecture three.
which is a prompting technique to have
your model output the reasoning before
outputting the the response.
So long story short, up until lecture
six, our LLM was having a prompt as
input directly outputting the output.
But in lecture seven, we said, sorry, in
lecture six, we said, uh, well, let's
have our LLM actually first output a
reasoning chain that the user may or may
not have access to before outputting the
final answer.
So you want to teach the LM to do that.
So how do you do that? Well, first
before doing this, I just want to show
you this chart which we saw which is the
performance of uh the model as we're
teaching it to produce these reasoning
chains. So people have typically
measured uh the improvement in
performance by comparing it to uh I
guess certain benchmarks and this one is
a popular one the AIM benchmark which is
the math math benchmark and we saw that
as the training progresses the accuracy
number of uh I guess what the LLM
outputs is increasing.
But back to what I was I was saying uh
the key technique that we use to teach
the model how to output these reasoning
chains is
leveraging the RL techniques that we saw
in lecture five. And in particular
um up until now we saw PO which was the
main RL algorithm that people were using
up to maybe last year and now people are
kind of prioritizing GRPO as an R
algorithm in order to teach the model to
be better at reasoning tasks.
And there are several reasons to do to
to that that I will explicit right now.
So we saw this illustration that
compared how GRPO was differing with PO
and if you can see in the graph uh there
are a few things that are different.
The first thing is that GRPO does not
rely on a value model.
So, who remembers what a value model is?
Yep.
Yes. Exactly. So, the value function is
trying to predict what the reward would
be if you um were to follow the policy
of the LLM. Um, and I guess it's a way
to have some baseline as to how good
some predictions are. You want to make
it more relative. So the value function
is a way for us to make these uh rewards
a little bit more relative to one
another. Um, and so that's what that's
how PPU was doing this. So it was having
a value model that was um making these
predictions and then we had uh this
generalized advantage estimation method
that was combining the reward
predictions
with the value function predictions in
order to have what we call advantages.
So advantages is how good your output is
compared to some baseline.
But then in contrast to that, GRPL said,
"Okay, tree, we don't need a value
function because it's, you know, too
expensive to to train, to maintain. What
we're going to do instead
is generate several completions
and then have some formula that compares
the rewards of these completion these
completions
to one another.
So it's going to have some relative
effect in a sense that it will make
things more relative
and in doing so you are actually not
uh needed to maintain and train a value
function and that's like one big
difference compared to PO.
Um and uh the second big difference
which is not represented in this
illustration uh is that uh GRPO is
typically an algorithm that people have
used in the context of
teaching your model to be better at
reasoning tasks.
And so we saw that these kinds of
problems
have a verifiable reward
because when you complete a math
problem,
you actually know the answer you need to
get to. So you don't need to train a
reward model to tell you how good your
final answer is because you you already
know the answer.
And so we saw that GRPO was in
particular used in the context of when
you actually don't even need a reward
model when you actually have a
verifiable reward. So at the end of the
day, the only two models you need to
keep are the policy model
and the reference model to be able to
just compare how far you are from the
reference model.
Cool. Um, I know this one was also a
challenging class, I guess. So far so
good. And this is also on on the final.
So, which is why I'm I'm taking things
more slowly for this second part of the
recap. So, is everything good so far?
Yeah.
Okay. Perfect. We also saw some
extensions of GRPO. So if you remember
there was um some kind of bias that was
um a result of the loss function of GRPO
having some normalization term that
penalized
tokens that were in shorter outputs.
So we saw that if you use GRPO in its
original case in its original form
we saw that after a certain point
the algorithm will incentivize your
model to produce longer and longer
answers longer and longer incorrect
answers.
And the reason why it does that is
because relative to short incorrect
answers,
it penalizes less
long incorrect answers. And so this is
the reason why there are some extensions
that people have worked on this year.
One of which was uh GRPO done rights. So
we saw like um that they basically
removed the normalization term and there
was another method that we saw it was
called depo dapo
which also had some variance
and that's for reasoning models and then
lecture seven we had a model that you
know we knew how to train it we knew how
to uh use it for uh reasoning tasks how
to train it to be better but now we
wanted the model to be useful and
interacting with outside systems.
So we saw one technique that is kind of
an an essential technique called rag
short for retrieval augmented generation
that is meant for you to be able to
fetch relevant documents from some
knowledge base in order to answer
a question or answer a prompt.
And the reason why you want to do that
is that the knowledge of your LLM is
including up to
the data that is up to the knowledge cut
updates which is the max dates of what
your LM has been trained on.
And from a practical standpoint,
I guess from what we see nowadays,
you're typically not training your LLM
daily or continuously. And so in cases
where you need your LLM to know about
things that happened recently or about
things that happened that were not
in your LM training data,
you want your LLM to have access to such
information. And so that's how rag is
very useful. So we saw that rag
dependent very heavily on the way it
retrieves data. So we saw that the
retrieval part was mainly composed of
two steps. So the first one was
candidate retrieval
which use which uses a by encoder kind
of setup where you're basically doing
some semantic search. So you're
computing the embedding of the query.
you have some precomputed embeddings of
the documents in your knowledge base and
you're taking the ones that maximize
some similarity score like let's say
some cosign similarity.
So the this first step is allowing you
to retrieve
um I guess a filtered version of the
potential documents and then typically
you have a second step which is called
ranking or reranking because the first
step already gives you a ranking which
has typically a more sophisticated
setup.
So it's a cross encoder kind of setup
where you have your query and your
document that are both fed to some model
and produces a more precise score
and then you use this final score to
rank the final results and you typically
choose the top let's say K
and then you add them to your prompt. So
it's the augmented part. So retrieval is
everything I mentioned so far and then
once you have the relevant documents you
add them in your prompt which is the
augmented part and you generate the
answer.
So the reason why I'm taking so much
time on rag is rag is such an important
concept also
if you were to you know have interviews
or you know also maybe in the exam who
knows um so I think it's a it's an
important concept to uh to have in mind
the second one that we saw was tool
calling
and tool calling is allowing your LLM to
leverage tools. The way it does that is
in two steps. The first step is for your
model to know which API there is out
there.
At the end of which your LLM says, okay,
I want to use this API and I want to use
it with these arguments.
And then you have an intermediary step
which is you just run your API with
these arguments.
And then the second step is you feed the
results of this operation back to the
LLM which then produces a final answer.
So that's how tool calling works. So if
you say to your LM okay you can use this
use this API this is how your LM would
leverage that.
And then we saw that modern-day agentic
workflows were leveraging both rag and
tool calling as key methods to um
perform actions.
And we saw an example detail example uh
which was such that you had some inputs
and then your LLM had a series of
different calls
um in order to perform some action and
then at the end of it it retrieves sorry
it returns an answer.
Cool. And then last lecture
we saw how we could evaluate LLMs which
is a much tougher thing to do now that
LLMs can do a bunch of different things.
So we first saw that there were some
rulebased metrics that people were using
before LMS came into play. metrics that
you may have heard like blur, rouge,
meor and so on, but the main limitation
was that they were not considering how
language could differ but still be
correct.
And so uh this key idea that we saw was
why not leverage LLMs to evaluate
outputs. And so there is this uh key
idea of LLM as a judge where you receive
as input the prompts
the model response along with the
criteria that you want the response to
be evaluated on.
And then you want your LM messages to
output two things. The first one is a
rationale for why a given score is
output.
along with that score.
So nowadays, LM as a judges, they're
typically outputting a binary response
either
uh pass or fail, true or false, just
because it's easier. And we're also
having the rational be output before the
score
because in practice it's something that
also improves the performance of uh the
element as a judge a little bit if you
want like reasoning models do by
outputting the reasoning chain before
they output the answer.
But then we also saw that there were uh
some biases that came with this
approach. We saw position bias which is
the way you present the elements to
compare matters. So if you present
something first then maybe the LLM will
just prioritize that first. Uh so there
was position bias, there was verbosity
bias which is your LLM just preferring
longer outputs.
Uh and self-enhancement bias was another
one where it prefers its own outputs.
Um and then we also saw a number of
benchmarks
uh that people use nowadays in order to
say how great their LLM is. So if you
see the releases that come out, there
are typically a bunch of metrics across
a number of different benchmarks that
people know about. So that spans uh
knowledge, the ability to reason, coding
which is very important because a lot of
applications are coding related
and then safety and then this is not an
an
extensive list so there's actually many
more dimensions.
Um
so yeah I think that's where we stopped
and it was last lecture
and this is all you are expected to know
for the final.
Everything after that is not going to be
part of the final.
Any questions
on this so far?
Cool. Okay. I'm expecting a hundreds for
everyone for the final. But yeah, um
I would say what I went through
is going to be foundational for the
final. So I guess if you understood
everything I said,
I think you're going to be ready for the
final. So um yeah, but if you have any
questions, you know, Shervin and I are
always here um to uh Oh, yeah. You have
a question?
Yes. So the question is, is the scope
for the final of lecture 5 to lecture 8?
Yes. So for midterm it was lectures 1 2
3 4 and this one is 5 6 7 8. So I guess
it's u equal equal size.
Cool.
Okay, great. So, with that said, we just
finished recapping this entire quarter
worth of lectures and now we're going to
go to the second item of today's menu,
which is looking at some trending
topics.
And so, I'm going to start with the
first one.
And I'm going to introduce it as
follows.
So if you remember we saw that the
transformer
was a concept and an architecture that
was first introduced in the context of
machine translation.
So it performed great. People said okay
it performs great on machine translation
why not try it on other text tasks. So
they tried it performs great
but now the question is can you not use
it for things other than text
it's a natural question right so in
order to answer that question I just
want us to remind ourselves that this
architecture is relying on this concept
of self attention
and this is what is making the
transformer work so Well,
so if we just recap what self attention
is, this uh illustration kind of does
the job quite well.
You have a query and then you have a
bunch of other elements which are
represented by your keys and your values
and you want to know which other
elements are actually relevant
in order to compute the embedding for
that query.
So right now we have only used tokens
you know text tokens
but text tokens
they're actually vectors.
So if you take those vectors
and you actually represent something
else than text
like for instance parts of an image.
The question is would the transformer
based on that kind of input also perform
well.
And so here the key question that I want
to ask is how can we adapt our
transformer
to work on non-ext input and for
instance here we can think of image
understanding input. So you have some
image and so it's a traditional um
computer vision task where you want to
know in which class this image belongs
to.
So you want to know if
having some transformer-based
architecture would work well in that
situation.
Well, the answer to that is well, first
in order to adapt it to this task,
you would take
the encoder part of the transformer
because in order to understand what is
in an image, you need to classify that
image in some sense.
So if you remember if there's one model
in what we saw that was working very
well for classification
was BERT because BERT is encoder only.
It computes meaningful embeddings that
can then be used for projection purposes
or for classification purposes.
So it's a very natural choice that here
we would have. So here we would just
keep the encoder part of the transformer
and then
have the self attention mechanism come
into play and um compute meaningful
embeddings that we could then project
for our relevant task. And this is
exactly what a group of researchers did
back in 2020.
So have you heard of VIT vision
transformer?
Yeah. No. Yeah. So what I described here
is exactly what they did.
So they took an image,
they divided that image into patches.
Those patches
were represented by some vectors.
And of course you have some some kind of
position information that allows you to
know where your your patch is in the
image.
And then you just put it through the
transformer encoder. So the encoder part
of the transformer
and you compute the representation
corresponding to the CLS class very
similar to birds and you would just
project that representation
over some classes of interest
and then you would perform your um your
uh I guess computation uh like this. So
what that paper found was that if you
train such a model on a lot of image
data on a lot of image data you then
outperform these traditional
convolutional neural network kind of
methods.
And so those kind of
uh remarkable
because so why is it remarkable? Because
in the vision case,
so there is this concept of inductive
bias where you want to gear your model
towards
looking at certain things in order to to
deduce the results.
So convolutional neural networks
are a kind of model that are designed in
a way for you to look at the image
in some you know sliding way. You know
you look at your image a little bit like
you would look at it in practice as a
human.
And people had hypothesized that such
such a bias such an indictive bias would
actually make sense for something like a
vision task.
So you contrast that with the vision
transformer
which is actually letting all parts of
the image attend to one another which
has on the other side very low inductive
bias. So what this paper showed was if
you give your model enough data
then it will actually learn how to
classify
um I guess your images in this in this
classes. So this was like kind of a
remarkable results.
Um so I think this is like pretty
remarkable and a nice extension of
everything we saw.
So with that in mind,
um I want us to just go through an end
toend example of how you would process
an image and go through that um vit so
vision transformer in order to make your
um prediction. So here you would take uh
like your favorite image that you would
just split into patches. So here you can
think of you predefining some uh fixed
size patches.
So here I would say like 3x3 let's say
and then each patch has some um fixed
number of pixels
and then what you do is for each patch
you try to have some vector
representation.
So you can think of each patch as so
what is a patch? So it's composed of
pixels.
So if each pixel has three values which
correspond to red, green and blue, then
you can find
a way to project those on some lower
dimensional flattened space
and you can learn how you would project
that through some kind of linear layer.
So
long story short, you just find a way to
associate a vector to each of these
patches
which you you then represent
every single one of your inputs. And
then you have of course a special
embedding for the CLS token which you
can also learn.
And you add the position embedding.
So you do the same for all of your
inputs and then very similar to birds
just put that through your encoder. Let
everyone interact with everyone
and then at the end of the day what you
care about is a representation of the
input that is meaningful. So typically
people take the encoded embedding of the
CLS token. So the reason why they take
that is one because it's a convention
but second one is this CLS token. So the
encoded embedding
is actually
an embedding that has interacted with
all other tokens through this self
attention mechanism.
So it has seen everything
and then you would project that CLS
token encoded embedding onto some class
through a feed for neural network in
order to predict your final class.
So in this case we know it's a picture
of a teddy bear. So here we would want
the model to classify this as a teddy
bear.
So far so good. Does that make sense?
Cool. Uh, so now, okay, we know how to
process
image input, right? Now, so another
question is how would you have your LLM
answer questions about your image, which
is something that you can do actually
nowadays. Like if you open chat GPT you
can input an image and ask it questions.
So
you would have two kinds of inputs. So
you would have an image which we saw we
can find a way to represent
and then the text which you now know
very well how to represent like with
tokens.
So the way you would
allow the model or let the model
process. All of this
is typically as follows. So there are
like a couple of methods. The first one
is the more most common one which is you
just feed everything as input.
So the image token as input, the um text
tokens as input and you have some
representation to have the model just
know that these are image tokens and
this is like text token and then you let
it generate an answer in a decoder only
fashion, auto reggressive fashion
exactly like you would do it
the first method and a lot of such
models are designed that way. So there
is for instance a very popular uh open
weight I believe um vision language
model VLM that's what they are called uh
model called lava
and this is how they do it. So they have
some encoder on the image parts uh that
produces some tokens that are then uh
concatenated with text tokens that are
input into the LLM.
So that's one method.
The second method which is less common
is to have the images be input at the
cross attention layer.
So here what you would do is you have
your text input
and then your image input. You don't put
it in the input. You actually let it
interact with the text tokens within the
cross attention layer.
And this is something that for instance
llama 3 had represented in their paper.
This technique is typically less common.
The first one is more common.
So I guess what I want to say is CME 295
focused on the transformer specifically
in the case of
texttoext problems. So text generation
is all you know this class
but we also have the transformer that
was used for non-ext applications. So
here we saw image understanding so
vision understanding with the vit and
then uh we will not have the time to say
this now but also for image generation
tasks we can also have parts of the
transformer be used in that architecture
and so you may uh you know hear about
diffusion transformer or multimodel
diffusion transformer that's actually
rely on the self attention mechanism
and um this is actually not an
exhaustive list. This is also something
that has been used in other uh domains
like recommendations, speech and so on.
So I guess I what I want you to remember
from this is that transformers
were like was an architecture that
performed very well for machine
translation tasks
but then it proved to perform very well
for other text related tasks
and it was then reused in a bunch of
other domains which also proved to be
quite successful. So I would just
encourage you after this class to also
keep an open mind for non-ext related
transformer applications and the ones
that I mentioned here are maybe just a
few first few pointers into the kind of
papers that you can look at.
Cool. So here we said that transformer
was something that came from the text
world that's also uh useful and used in
other worlds.
Now I want to tell you about something
else that was uh I guess used and useful
in the non-ext world that may be useful
in the text world
and I want to tell you about
diffusionbased LLMs.
So who has heard the term diffusion?
Who knows about diffusion?
Yeah,
cool. So we will see how we can apply
that to LLM. So this is a very trendy
topic. I believe the first paper started
in the early 2020s, but I guess it's
only now that people are starting to
have this really work.
I just want to start with a motivation
which is that up until now we have taken
for granted the fact that our LLM is an
auto reggressive LLM and by auto
reggressive what do I mean by that?
So it takes some input
and what the LLM tries to do is to
predict the next token. So given
everything so far, we predict the next
token.
We do that and then we take that token
that we just predicted along with
everything that we have predicted so far
and then we again
predict the next token.
We predict it and we go again and again
up until you know finishing the sequence
with that end of sequence token which
makes the generation stop.
So this is a true auto reggressive
generation as in we take the input so
far in order to predict the next token
and then we repeat this process until
the end.
So it's something that people now try to
kind of give it a name which is like
auto reggressive model kind of model.
So, ARM, if you kind of see this
notation, that's what it means. Um, the
problem with that kind of paradigm is
that inference time generation
is actually not something you can
parallelize
because you always need what's before in
order to predict the next one.
But I just want to say that inference
time generation is not paralyzable. But
training is paralyzable.
So if you remember the way we do
training is we input all the tokens
that we want our model to predict and
then we let the model generate tokens
out of this. So basically in a decoder
only setting you have this causal mask
which lets your model not cheat if you
want and not use the future ones.
So I just want to say that when I say
that uh this paradigm is not paralyzable
I just want to emphasize on the fact
that it's a inference time that I'm
saying training time you can actually
paralyze that quite well.
So as I mentioned that's one of the
reasons why people have tried to look at
other paradigms
and in particular um so if you know
about diffusion you know that it works
very well for the vision domain
and so people have tried adapting
this paradigm for the text generation
case
and uh so this is like a bunch of
screenshots we took from announcement
that happened this year. So for instance
uh earlier this year there was an
experimental text diffusion model from
Google that they presented during the IO
event
um which was very impressive because it
led to a lot of speedups. And then we
have some um like different startups. So
Inception is one of them uh that made
headlines I believe a couple of weeks
ago or last week no sorry a month ago um
that also are pursuing this route. Um,
so all of that to say that this
direction is a very trendy and hot
direction that potentially has a lot of
promise.
But the key issue with this is that text
is discrete
whereas images are continuous.
And we're going to see why that
distinction that I just made matters.
So I'm going to try to explain to you
what diffusion is in two minutes.
So
in the image world
in order to generate an image
what people typically do is they start
from noise
and then they try to generate some
image.
Now now you may wonder okay why noise?
Well, you cannot do something that's um
you know uh auto reggressive because I
guess like if you were to say okay let's
predict the pixels one at a time uh it's
just not tractable because there are
many pixel in in an image and this is
typically not how you produce uh an
image but some other reasons are that uh
noise is just something that you can
model very well with uh some very
popular distributions so gausian
distribution if you know about
it has very nice properties. Um, also
noise is very easy to sample. So, it's
very easy to start with that. Um, noise
is also a way for you to introduce
randomness because you don't necessarily
want to always produce the same image.
You want to have uh the uh I guess
choice of generating images that are
slightly different from one another.
And uh just mathematically it works
quite well. And um speaking of that, the
goal is to learn
some transformation that would allow you
to go from noise
to the target image distribution.
So all of what I said here is just kind
of reasons for me to tell you, okay,
noise is actually a choice that is quite
natural to start with in order to
generate an image.
And to give you an analogy,
um let's suppose you're a sculpture
sculptor. So the person who does
sculptures.
So if you want to do a sculpture, you
typically start with some rock.
But then rocks are, you know, different
from one another. They always have uh
things that are unique to them. And
still you would focus on what to remove
in order to obtain the end sculpture. So
you can think of the rock as being your
noise
and your end result as being your target
data distribution.
So I just want to have this quote by
Michelangelo. So the sculpture is
already complete within the marble block
before I start my work. It is already
there. I just have to chisel away the
superus material. The reason why I'm
reading that is you can have a a nice
analogy between what Michelangelo said
and the process of denoising
the noise to get an image.
So this is all just motivating how image
generation is done. So you start from
noise
and you want to generate an image. So
the way you do that for diffusion is to
learn some transformation
that would allow you to go from noise
to image.
So you have two steps. I mean you have
more than two steps but we have these
two main steps for diffusion models
where you first want to start from clean
images
and you add noise gradually
until until you obtain some very noisy
image
and then from that
what diffusion models try to do is to
predict the noise to remove in order to
obtain the image.
So, it's a little bit like, you know,
you're the sculpture sculpture person
and you have your rock. You just want to
learn what pieces of rock you need to
remove in order to obtain your final
piece of art.
So, this is what diffusion is. So it
works pretty well because noise as I
mentioned is typically something that
people draw
from a gausian distribution.
Gausian distributions are mathematically
very well defined have a lot of nice
properties. So that's why they work so
well.
But now the question is how would you
adapt this to the text world? Because in
the text world as you know we're talking
about tokens.
Tokens are discrete.
So there's not this concept of you know
adding noise. Cannot have that.
So pe what people have tried to um to do
was to find a text equivalent that would
make sense. And this is what the current
research
points to which is that noise is to
images what the mask token is to text.
So mask is just a way for us to just not
have the information coming from one
part of the sequence.
And I just want to go through the
revised two-step process that we saw
here for text.
So here for the forward process
instead of noising your input
you would just have more and more
inputs that would be masked.
So that's the for process and at the end
you would just obtain a sequence full of
mass tokens.
So what you want to do is to learn
some
model that allows you to unmask
these mass tokens in a way that
reconstructs the original sentence.
So there's some math that goes into it.
Obviously in a few minutes we will not
have time to go into that. But I just
want to emphasize on the key idea which
is
you want to do diffusion but in a way
that makes sense for text inputs.
And the way the way it would make sense
is to consider
the noise for images as being mask
tokens
for text input.
Cool. And so with that in mind, you have
a bunch of models that are being
released these days which are called
masked diffusion models, MDM.
So whenever you see MDM now, you know
what kind of model we're talking about.
So notations are still very um not very
well defined. So it may change in the
future. But one other term you will see
out there is also DLLM diffusion based
LLM
and this is what it's doing. So instead
of predicting a token in an auto
reggressive fashion like one at a time,
what it does is that at inference time
it goes from a completely masked
input sequence
and it tries to predict what tokens were
behind these mass tokens.
So of course um you know in a real life
setting you would have some prompts
here. you would have some prompts. So of
course in order to predict this answer
you would have some conditioning. So you
would tell your model okay given this
prompts you're going to start with all
these mass tokens just try to predict
what the answer is.
So in case you're having trouble with
the intuition. So I also had trouble in
the beginning you know why would it make
sense for text to be solved in a
diffusion manner because typically when
you write you write one word at a time.
So one helpful way to think about this
is
let's suppose you want to write a
speech.
So you would not directly write your
speech in a linear way.
You would first have like a rough plan.
you say okay I'm going to talk about
this in the first place second third you
have some kind of draft
and then you try to refine what is in
each of these sections
so you can think of diffusion as kind of
working like this so it tries to have a
course to fine refinement of the output
so it can predict things that are you
know after a certain token that has not
been predicted But you can think of this
as being
something that goes from a very drafty
version to a very refined version.
So that's what I think about this
process. Hopefully that's helpful. And
the key advantage here is that the
decoding is now done in much fewer
forward passes
because previously you had to do as many
forward passes as there were tokens to
predict.
But here for diffusion you only need to
do as many passes as there are steps in
your diffusion process. And the number
of steps is something you can fix.
So the higher the step, the more high
quality your output is, but it's
typically much lower than the length of
your output.
So that is the core reason why
this model is so much faster than the
auto reggressive one.
And um of course you know uh we don't
have uh that much time but in case
you're curious in case you're interested
after the final once you're completely
freed in terms of uh things to think of
uh just put some references that could
be help helpful. There's a paper that
came out earlier this year called LADA
large language
uh diffusion
model with masking. Actually, I don't
remember the full acronym, but it is
actually going through the math and why
the thing that I just mentioned works.
Uh, and then there's like a bunch of
other papers that would also be helpful.
So, the links are in the at the bottom
of the slide in case you're interested.
And I just want to go through two last
things before giving it to Shervin.
So first on the advantages of this new
paradigm.
So the first one is the speed.
So as we mentioned it's going to be much
faster than traditional auto reggressive
models especially for outputs that are
longer. And so some benchmarks they even
say that it's something along the lines
of 10x faster.
So for cases like coding it can be very
powerful because you may have to do
several model calls and uh you know you
as a user you're just waiting for that
code to happen and you know just having
a lower latency makes a lot of
difference.
The other thing is that the nature of
this approach is actually considering
the text as a whole in order to make the
predictions.
And so there's a category of coding
tasks that are called fill in the middle
which is about trying to figure out you
know you have a bunch of code and you
want to know what's missing.
in the middle and so fill in the middle
and diffusion models are typically
better formulated for the kind these
kinds of tasks because they can consider
I guess input from multiple directions
and um you know that's why this approach
can be probably something that can be
useful
for some applications.
So in terms of the current work, so
these models they look great you know
what I mentioned to you looks great but
the performance was not on par with the
current frontier models at least for
some time but it's something that may
change.
So the papers that I mentioned they are
actually posting performance that is
kind of catching up with the models that
are auto reggressive.
So there is some promise in there. And
then uh the other line of work is just
to adapt
all the techniques that people have come
up with uh like for instance you know
reasoning chains. How do you adapt that
for diffusion?
Um like you know and so on. You know
there are so many techniques that are
intrinsically more
better suited for auto reggressive
kinds of models that can be adapted for
that
and that's what people are working on.
So long story short,
what we saw was that things we saw in
this class could be used in other
domains. Like for instance, we saw the
vision transformer
uh that was borrowing the transformer
for vision related tasks. But we also
saw that things from other domains
could also be used in the text world.
And that's what we saw with diffusion
LMS. Um, and so this is probably, you
know, of course a subset of everything
that's happening.
And so with that, I think we're
concluding our second item of our menu.
And um, I'm going to just give it to
Shervin.
Thank you, Ashin.
And with that, welcome to the last part
of the season finale of CM295.
And as Ein mentioned, now is the time
for some closing thoughts and see um
what we can get away from this class and
uh concepts that are u neighboring to
it.
Uh so first Afin went through the
concept of diffusion and images and we
saw some similarities. we could draw
with text. And now we're going to see
what kinds of inspirations have both
modalities taken from each other. And
we're going to see um that actually like
a lot of things can be um reused.
So the first thing that I want to
mention in terms of what has been reused
is the architecture part. So Afinen uh
mentioned this uh like diffusion concept
that was born in the field of images but
that was taken for text and was able to
yield uh lower latency like a higher
speedups which is great when you're a
user. Uh so this was one example of a
win.
Uh and then on the other direction um
traditionally images have been dealing
with um convolutions mostly as as uh
model architecture type but uh these
papers saw that replacing convolutions
with transformers
uh was very good even um yielding better
results. So all these latest
diffusionbased papers in the field of
images typically use transformers
and then here I'm linking one of the
papers that Afin already uh briefly went
through.
But not only uh is it the architecture
sides that is uh that that is the
subject of pollination between these
modalities. You could even think of
other kinds of components like the
input. And for this one I want to
mention the example of deepsek OCR. So I
don't know if you've heard of this
paper. It just came out very recently
and contrary to what the names the name
suggests. So, OCR stands for optical rec
uh like recognition, character
recognition and it's usually a field
that tries to convert some scanned image
into text but actually that paper
doesn't boast some improvement on the
OCR task itself rather it showed that
you could learn some function that
reconstructs
text tokens based on vision tokens and
not only on vision tokens on very few
vision tokens. So it showed that the
representation power of patches of
images as tokens was very strong. And
you have some researchers that bring
some rationale to it like um you know
hey tokenizers are not the best tool
anyway. and then things in patches
convey the meaning of text already with
the example of emojis and so on that you
would otherwise need to represent with
way more tokens in text. Um and then
another example I want to mention is
even when you look inside the
architectures
some of the tricks uh can be reused and
adapted in each field. So here I'm
mentioning the example of rope which fin
mentioned in the recap that was used in
text to represent uh the relative
position of tokens and in the case of
images or even multimodel setting where
you have the presence of both text and
image within the architecture. you're
able to adapt that trick uh by
reformulating it in 2D. So here uh the
figure shows how you can attribute rope
positions in the 2D grids and how you
could place text tokens such that the
relative computation of position still
makes sense.
And you know even beyond that I would
say that the ongoing research for
transformers is very much alive and
people are still figuring out all the
details that we're working with today
and you see refinements all the time
coming uh in terms of new papers. So
it's um you know it's something that is
still developing
and
you can look at it from multiple angles.
One is each of these design decisions
that we've had they are still being
iterated on. So like I'm listing a few
items here as an example. So one is the
optimizer side. You might be familiar
with the atom optimizer and its update
role which has been popular for quite
some time and it seems that uh state is
being challenged with a newer paper. So
I referenced here the Kim K2 paper that
came out a few months ago that uh
introduces a new kind of optimizer
called muon and the latest version of
that muon clip seems to be a potential
candidate for this optimizer to to
become like the new standard. So this
field even
like as basic as it can be is still
developing
but it's not only the optimizer side you
also have the topic of normalization
where Afin mentioned that the difference
between the original transformer paper
and what you see today in LLM papers
um you don't have the same kind of
normalization anymore in the past you
had postnorm
but Now you have pre-norm which brings
the normalization earlier on in the
layer.
Uh but beyond that design choice of the
loca location of normalization you even
have the type of loca uh of
normalization that changes. So the
transformer paper used layer norm but
these days you might see other kinds of
uh normalization techniques like RMS
norm which uses less parameters and
others. So the theory behind it is not
set just yet.
Uh so you have other kinds of
parameters. Um Ashin mentioned the
grouped query attention paper and you
see these days in LLM papers not a fixed
design rather every paper adopts their
uh their own technique. Sometimes you
see one kind of u attention used at a
given layer but then it switches and
different papers take different design
decisions so it's not set in stone. Um
then you also have activation functions.
So traditionally in deep learning a lot
of emphasis was put on ReLU which is uh
very simple and used worked very well.
But in the world of LLM the shift was
towards uh ReLU like um activation
functions but not exactly relu. So you
had gausian error linear uh units you
you had like other kinds and the the
research there is still ongoing. So you
you still see um you still see new
activation functions coming in uh now
and then and then you have also whether
to take the design option of uh
considering the LLM as ane or not and uh
even the number of layers of your LLM
and other hyperparameters like number of
heads
um size of the number of units in the
FFN all of that is still up for debates
uh in terms of like design decisions. So
it's not fixed.
Uh and then another area of research I
want to mention is the data part which
is crucial.
So the first LLMs they enjoyed a
relatively clean state of things because
you could scrape the internet and hope
for a lot of data that was for sure
human generated. So you could learn
these patterns from quote unquote a high
quality source even though it's like not
in high quality format when you look at
typical internet data but it was still
uh generated by human. So these days the
state has changed. You type anything you
want in your favorite search browser.
Chances are the first results are 80%
LLM generated. So are we doomed?
Maybe not
uh because actually you see the
development of more and more work in
data curation. So in the past you would
just scrape the whole internet and train
next token prediction on it. But now you
have more and more this work of curating
data sets of interest and you have
companies that work on it and you have
the emergence of newer
fine-tuning modes. So in the past you
had pre-training and then fine-tuning.
Now you have pre-training, mid training
and fine-tuning. And the mid-training
part trains still on a large corpus of
data but higher quality. So people are
finding ways around it. Um and I would
say the picture is not all grim but it's
just that we need to do more work in
order to be um to have meaningful data
at hand. And the paper that is linked
and at the bottom of the of the slide is
dealing with the phenomenon of what if
you were training on LLM generated data
and it's talking about a concept called
model collapse
and it says that
LLM generated text is typically less
diverse.
So the data distribution that you would
see at training time changes and it
leads to less meaningful learning at
training time which is why it's
typically bad and it motivates the need
for more work on the data part.
Okay. Nice. Um and then you know even
taking a step back on the very
architecture we've been um using all
along is it the best one? it's not it's
not clear. So that itself is an area of
research and um future breakthroughs
might come from redesigning this uh this
architecture.
Okay. So in the past few years a lot of
the research that we have seen has been
on improving benchmarks
even more each time. So you have a set
of benchmarks. Everyone tries to get the
best results. So it's a natural trend
because you want to have more and more
powerful models that fulfill all your
use cases. But let's say we reach a
point where all the use cases we care
about are solved.
Then what?
So I think we're going to see the
emergence of this second border of the
Parto Frontier where we care most about
making predictions from LLM cost
effective um and still very high
quality.
So uh we see this emergence of uh
smaller and smaller LLMs like I think it
has been dubbed small language models
SLM uh like in the literature and um
yeah typically you hear sometimes LLM
providers say that they lose money even
on the highest tier plans. So I think it
reflects the fact that you need to be
smarter in the compute that you spend
for serving LLM queries at test time and
uh yeah I think this this will motivate
more and more uh this line of research
in the coming years
and then there is another area that
we've not touched on at all in this
class which is the hardware part. So
typically the kind of device that you
use to train these LLMs are GPUs which
are great at one thing matrix multiply.
Uh but the thing is uh we've kept these
kinds of architectures to train our
models even though the architecture
doesn't only need matrix multiplies as a
foundational
um
like atomic unit of compute. the uh self
attention world and the transformer
world has all these special needs. Um
you know the Q K transpose part we saw
was actually very expensive which has
motivated papers such as flash attention
to as Afin mentioned actually forgo of
some of the data for the sake of not
doing too much movement on the memory
side
even if it meant recomputing the same
things afterwards. And then a lot of
work has been on optimizing where the
flow of memory within the GPU resided.
And this shows that maybe you need a
more um optimized uh hardware
architecture in order to uh to to um to
solve these use cases. So there is a
recent paper that came out um that
actually encodes all of these operations
as part of the hardware. So in the past
the core um the core operation that the
GPU was great at is matrix multiply and
based on it you try to build all of the
input output that you want. But here
this paper that came out I think in
September
shows a proof of concept where you can
all do all of these computations as a
side effect of implementing input and
outputs with analog signals. So you have
all of these computations that are
embedded as part of the hardware and
based on pulses as input that simulates
your array values. These uh hardware
architectures
have some physical properties like you
could think of kirhoff uh law in the
like field of um I think intensity um
you can add them up and it uses
properties like this to have um what you
need as input and just read out the
result uh as output.
So uh when uh the paper simulated this
kind of architecture uh they observed
without uh too much surprise quite a bit
of improvement both on the latency and
energy saving parts. Uh both explained
because you don't need to do the
computations yourself. Uh you just get
them as a side effect of uh of your
hardware.
Now I want to take a step back and look
at our users at our use cases of LLMs
today and what could lie ahead. Uh what
could be the most exciting for you. So
today we've seen that in just a few
years I think it has become quite
important to know how to use them if you
want to speed up everything you you do
in your daily life. So a few lectures
ago we talked about the coding case
where um do you have all these AI
assistant coding tools that um enable
enable you to turn into code some
natural language prompts. So you just
you know ask for something and it will
uh help you do that task with a
so-called agent mode. And um this is
just something that you would do as an
engineer. But even beyond that uh other
use cases are deeply impacted by it
because you have um a lot of problems
that today can be turned into a text to
query or text to code problem. Uh so you
could think of even the visualization
world. you could um so for example there
was a launch from Google uh recently
that showed that you could uh generate
visualizations on the fly based on some
principles and this is already changing
um quite a bit the
picture of what you can do today. Uh
something else that I think is used by
most people actually today when using
these chat bots is general uh like being
a general assistant. So you ask about
common facts and all the facts that it
has learned at training time becomes
useful. It browses the web um more
efficiently than you and converts into
natural language the things that you
care about. Um but then there are also
other domains that were impacted by it.
So you could think creativity where a
lot of jobs such as marketing uh or
others rely on uh getting something out
of a blank page and usually if you start
from a draft it's much easier to get
something done rather than just thinking
of it from from scratch. So it's used as
an eight here. And also one use case
that I've seen in class that I think is
is great that some of you do you know
sometimes I talk about something or Afin
talks about something and I see people
typing typing on JGPT related concepts
and I think it's very smart to do that
because brainstorming
the concepts that you learn is great for
actually grasping the concepts of
interest and getting that early feedback
loop is uh very useful for learning. So
I have a lot of hopes regarding uh how
like how great of a time it is for you
to learn as opposed to maybe uh you know
a nice time maybe 10 years ago. So yeah
keep doing that and I think it will be a
growing use case.
So looking forward
um so I said tomorrow on the slide but
actually two days ago there was a launch
uh that went in the direction of what I
was thinking about which is uh like all
the agentic things that we talked about
they are still very much confined into
people that know about the field like
everyday people they wouldn't typically
use quote unquote
agentic workflows. So I think one field
of development that we will see more and
more is all these use cases being
democratized. So people can now create
things that can be useful to them with
easier
um you know mediums just natural
language no need to code.
uh moving forward uh to later um so all
this AI assistant coding that I was
mentioning you could think of it as
helping you browse the internet in a
very natural fashion so it seems right
now when you just execute tasks you're
way too microscopic in what you do and
this is typically what uh AI assistant
could help you do so there are like
recent product launches that reflect
these growing interest such as chat
GPT's atlas. So I think it launched in
October. I don't know if they released
some public number uh on usage. I
suspect it's still timid because you
still have challenges when it comes to
security. Uh anyone could inject some uh
bad prompt in there and maybe exfiltrate
things from you, but I'm sure the
community will come up with uh more ways
to get around it. So in the past you had
https for example to say that the
connection was secure. Maybe tomorrow
you'll have some certificate that will
guarantee that a site website is safe
for AI assistant browsing.
um and looking even at a higher level,
maybe just browsing on your uh desktop
or your mobile phone at the LLM level.
Uh at the OS level might be um something
that the LLM can u can help. So when we
talked about agents, we mentioned how um
nonreliable it could be because as you
have more and more steps, the
probability for a failure increases and
stabilizing predictions is something of
interest.
And um even in the longer run, I think
one test that we can have in mind as to
how far we've come is whether the common
use case of having a customer service
that is served by AI is truly useful. So
I don't know about you, but every time I
have a problem and I'm on the phone and
I hear some AI assistant maybe LLM
powered robot and like you know quick
quick I want a human. I don't want that.
And uh and I think it shows how hard
this space is, the space of problems is
because human has way more dimensions of
of value that an LLM could bring. So
empathy,
um like groundedness, there are some
things that you and I we perceive as you
know things that make sense even though
they're not in our system prompts. So I
think there there are hard problems to
to solve there.
And even moving forward
um there are some key challenges that we
have with the current architecture. So
um we saw during the class that you had
to go through a training process that u
went to like fix some weights but these
weights are not changing afterwards. And
we use tricks such as rags a rag or
tools to get around this issue. But
could we think of a system that learns
continuously? I think that is an open
question. Then there is a topic of
hallucinations which I put into
quotation marks because I'm not sure if
it's fair to say that the LLM
hallucinates just because we've trained
the LLM to predict the next token by
nature, not map statements to facts. So
hallucinating is in some sense a core
design uh choice of the these LLMs. Uh
personalization, interpretability,
safety, the the list goes on.
Um now I want to briefly cover
what you can um like how you can
exercise this muscle of staying up to
date from now. So you have archive that
uh usually contains all these great
greatest and latest papers that you can
take a look at. Of course the venues
like new rips right now are great to
highlight papers um like some papers
uh and then uh I highly encourage you be
besides the papers uh looking at the
associated code bases that the authors
provide. So right now it's a common
place to just provide the implementation
of what you are proposing and I think
it's very insightful to learn the
concepts
and uh there is a paper with code that
existed in the past and that has been
replaced by hugging facees uh trending
papers which I think is a good place to
to take a look at the latest uh methods
and then um on the uh social network
side uh Twitter or X uh has a lot of u a
lot of the latest that is often
discussed. So you have a strong
community there and if you have an
account on that social media you have a
lot of great people to follow um to like
stay updated but also you have resources
on YouTube uh with a highlight on Yanik
Kilchshire which I think was the first
uh YouTuber to cover the transformer
paper back in 2017 in great detail and I
think you know some of these YouTubers
they're very good at um talking through
um like papers in great detail.
And another highlight is Andrish Karpath
uh who was at Stanford about 10 years
ago and he's I think one of the best
educators out there. So I highly
recommend his videos and you have a
company blogs that are also great
and
uh like this study guide that we
associated with the class. Um, so we've
had it for this year and what we'll try
to do uh in the coming years is try to
keep it updated at least on a yearly
basis. So you can consider this resource
as maybe some companion and we've got
the chance to collaborate with uh
experts around the world to make it
available in other languages in case
you're interested.
And taking a step back, just want to say
that Afin and I were very grateful to
teach this class this quarter. Um, thank
you so much for coming here, you know,
on Friday evening, which is quite
telling cuz, uh, you know, Friday
evening is usually time for fun, not for
lectures. And also now I think it's
probably your last lecture of the whole
quarter because uh, yeah, next week is
finals. So yeah, thank you for coming
and for asking all these great
questions. You were one of the reasons
why this class was so great and
interactive.
Also, thank you to the folks who are
watching online from home. I was one of
you uh eight years ago. I would uh
almost never go to class, always
watching lectures from home from a cozy
place. I hope the lectures were
entertaining
and that you got something from it.
Um, and I couldn't conclude
uh without bringing our favorite teddy
bear one last time. Thanking you uh all
for your attention and wishing you all
the best. Thank you.